hello everyone and welcome back to the
finals of the skilling open
uh 2020. it's magnus carlson versus
wesley so and this is the first game
uh between the two of them it just ended
so i decided to show it immediately uh
because you know why not
uh and uh let's just dive straight into
it magnus has the white pieces and he
opens it with
d4 now we have knight to f6 c4
e6 knight to f3 and d5 the queen's
gambit declined this on the board
and knight to c3 uh we have c5 and uh
magnus capture c capture sunday five the
semitarsh is on the board we have
captures on d4
magnus captures on d4 and now e captures
on d5 and now magnus advances the pawn
to e4
temporarily offering pawn uh but uh he
he wants to trade queens and mess up
wesley's castling privileges so d
captures an e4 magnus trades on the
eight we have king captures and now
knight the g5 so threatening to win back
the pawn but also
the actual threat is just knight
captures an f7 check which would win the
rook
so here bishop to e6 defending but also
allowing white to double up the black
spawns
but this is all still a known theory
captures captures and now bishop to c4
by magnus going after the e6 pawn so
here
king e7 wesley defends it and magnus
castles and here knight b to d7 and here
magnus took some three minutes to decide
on a move
and uh this position still exists in the
database there is one game
from the 2015 uh poker stars isle of man
uh masters tournament where rook the e1
was played in a game between irving
lammy and
simon williams uh but here uh we uh the
end the game ended in a draw but here
instead of rookie one we have bishop to
e3 by magnus and
it's as of move 13 that we have a
completely new game so this is basically
where our
uh where our game starts so wesley
continues with rook to c8
brings the brings rook into the game
with tempo as the bishop is under attack
and magnus needs to figure out where
where the movie do you want to go back
bishop to e2 bishop to b3 he retreats to
b3
and now knight to c5 so getting the
knight into the game attacking the
bishop on b3 and here magnus gives up
the bishop for knight captures captures
and not rooked
after e1 going after the e4 pawn you
want to
win back your pawn so here we have g6
preparing to fiance to this dark square
bishop the b2 pawn might be a nice
target
and now knight captures an e4 we have
knight captures and
rook captures on e4 so magnus wins back
his pawn
and he also wants to go after the uh the
e6 pawn so here
e5 as there's currently a threat of just
capturing that pawn
so e5 the rook defends it and also the
bishop will
help out with the defense and now f4 of
course
as the king is on e7 uh you wanna
try and win a pawn here so bishop g7 and
rook a to e1 uh we have rook to f8 and
here
f captures on e5 so magnus grabs the
pawn
rook to f5 now with a triple attack on
the pawn here and if uh
not this one just just this and if
magnus wants to defend it he needs to
advance it and then
give up the b2 pawn which is what he
does we have e6
and bishop captures on b2 so now the
material on the board is completely
equal however the bishops are of
opposite colors
and it's very questionable if either
player can make make use of this
so if magnus can get something like rook
d1 with the d7 check-in then he probably
will be winning but
wesley will try of course everything to
prevent that so rook
to d1 threatening rook to d7 and wesley
stops it
rook to c7 and now magnus uh continues
pushing
pushing his pawns g4 attacks the rook
rook back to f8 and now comes king to g2
just
slowly but surely improving his position
uh wesley starts pushing on the queen
side as well
b5 and now rook to e2 challenging the
bishop here
bishop back to c3 and now rook to e3
again challenging the bishop and
bishop to b for now so rook e the d3
uh now doubling up on the d file rook to
d7 is the idea but wesley says
this is not not an actual threat i'm
just going to continue playing on the
queen side so a5
we looked at the seven check as it was
prepared
rook captures and now rook captures if
you go e captures then
there's no actual danger here wesley can
just even block the
the d file and then just pick up the
pawn so instead
after real capture 7 we have rook
captures with check the 6 pawn is still
nicely protected
king to f6 and now rook to b7 going
after the queen side pawns and here
just a4 attacking carlson's bishop so
magnus needs to decide
whether to move the bishop where to move
the bishop or
well there are a lot of interesting
moves here but even feel free to pause
the video and try to figure out what
magnus played here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able uh to
do it congratulations as the magnus
played a most interesting move
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show he played g5 with
check here and he sacrificed a pawn but
we will show what happens if you just
play something like
you could play bishop captures on a4
it's not an issue b
captures and then rook captures on b4 uh
rook day it for example defending and
now rook to e4 you go
behind your pass pawn king is seven and
uh black is down upon but he should he
should be able to hold this so this is
what happens if you go for b
bishop captures on a4 on the other hand
you could also go for rook captures on
b5 and allow a trait like this
a captures on b3 rook captures on b4 and
now b
captures an a2 but again after this
captures and captures
it's going to be a draw
equal material and there's nothing
either side can do so here
magnus saw this and he decided uh well
to try and push for a win
with the g5 and this is a very sneaky
idea uh because
if you don't capture it everything else
loses for example if you try
let's say king to e5 just e7 is enough
for a win
because after the rook blocks the pawn
uh rook captures on b5 comes with
check and it doesn't matter where the
king goes you're just gonna capture on
a4
and there's nothing for you to do the
bishop is under attack you need to move
it now comes
rugby six check and after let's say king
c7 rook to c6 check
king to b7 and now let's say a rook here
attacks uh the bishop ended the rook
this is just one of the lines about all
of the lines are winning so instead
after g5 like i said capture sun g5
rook captures on b5 with check and now
wesley played
rook to f5 and uh
here it's well it's a very interesting
move because you need to go back with
king to f6 wesley played rook to f5
but now there's a problem uh because
here magnus played rook captures on b4
we have a captures on b3 and now magnus
doesn't recapture but rather he plays
e7 and now uh now to wesley's horror he
sees what's happening
because wesley's plan probably uh when
he decided not to go back with the king
but rather to
block with the rook on f5 was rook to e5
but this doesn't work
and even feel free to pause the video
here and
find a win for magnus again while i give
you a couple of seconds
in this hypothetical line
so again congratulations to everyone who
found it uh
and to those who just want to enjoy the
show
it's rook to b5 this is a classic idea
uh
just not allowing the the rook to move
anywhere since the king is
on the same file as the rook you would
have to capture here
and then uh that's just it white gets
the queen into the game and it's game
over
the rook is under attack you don't even
get a chance to push or pass pawn it's
just all over
so here wesley saw that and he decided
to go for b captures on a2 he said okay
you'll get a queen into the game but
i'll get a queen into the game as well
so magnus brought a queen into the game
uh wesley also
brought a queen into the game but
whenever we have two queens brought into
the game
uh the player that's allowed to give
checks first has a huge advantage
most of the time so here 27 check by
magnus
and now king to h6 by wesley but now
comes
rook to h4 check so there's no move for
the black king you have to block with
the rook
as all of the squares are covered by the
white queen so rook blocks
and the knob comes uh or rather
uh yeah there's nothing you can do here
rook rook h5
check and now comes queen to f8 with
check
forcing wesley to choose between king g5
and queen to for checkmate
uh or uh by blocking with the queen
queen to g7
blocking but now comes queen to f4 check
again the rook is pinned so the only
move is g5 and now comes queen to d6
with check again nothing for you to do
uh you have to block with the queen
queen to g6 and here magnus played queen
to f8 with
check queen to g7 and now uh
of course the winning idea all of you
see it uh rook captures on h5
with check of course and it was in this
position that wesley so resigned the
game and the game one goes to magnus
carlsen
who is on a nice path now to become the
the first ever champion of the of the
skilling open tournament
here we resign because after king
captures uh well it
is just game over or or king to g6 for
that matter
it's all the same with king g6 then
you're gonna sacrifice the rook again
and now you remove the king and rook
captures or or you're capturing them
queen captures with with
uh check doesn't really matter uh but
yeah
after real captures on h5 wesley
resigned and a brilliant victory for
magnus carlsen in round one
uh who was able to take a pretty much uh
it doesn't matter that position is a
draw there are still resources and
magnus found those resources
by playing that the g5 move uh which
forced wesley to you know
take a lot more into consideration and
he was able to pull off a win
so uh that's uh that's the game i do
hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank david kimura paul
myers gavin pierce uh
greatgambit69 uh that's his uh
nickname unleashes if you guys want to
challenge him and also pranityamoto for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon
continuing the coverage of this match uh
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day